c'était sensationnel et les besoins mais
c'était bien comme il a beaucoup crié
les grandes sensations
ouais voilà la sensation est devenu un
forum c'est l'événement chaque année la
fête foraine de tours
les portes sont tout juste ouverte et de
nombreux curieux sont déjà présents de
la sensation et de la peur c'est ce que
recherche le public
cette année l'accent a donc été mis sur
la hauteur avec trois nouveaux manèges
le sky flyers qui vous emmène à 30
mètres de haut le boomerang qui va vous
faire toucher les nuages et le super
bowl mais également quelques attractions
pour les amoureux comme la grande roue
avec la possibilité de s'offrir un joli
panorama de la ville de tours tout en
dégustant une pomme d'amour
quant au petit ils ont eu aussi leur
grande roue ou encore l'indémodable
pêche à la ligne
la fête foraine de tours fait partie des
aides et des plus grosse fête foraine de
france elle draine un public de plus en
plus important et elle est très attendue
par les taureaux chevaux et des taureaux
jeunes un public de plus en plus
important c'est aussi ce que recherchent
les propriétaires des manèges
si le temps est avec nous c'est une
bonne foi cette fête foraine sera
présente jusqu'au 21 mai l'occasion de
venir dépasser ses limites